a vocal anon go and her colleague are
setting up the livestock fences again
rain or shine it has to be done the
grazing cows have to be moved regularly
or they'll destroy the pastures that's
something the 24 year old has learned
here in Cameroon we just use the soil
carelessly we don't know that the soil
needs some time to regenerate its
fertility but here in Germany it's a
whole topic the trained farmer has been
volunteering here for a year driving the
tractor took a bit of getting used to at
first and she was amazed to discover
that the fences around the animals were
electric because I went to die if they
touch it they are going to die but then
I learned that a voltage is not so high
for the cows to die by then it's just
enough to keep the cows from running
away although the cows don't seem
exactly eager to leave any time soon in
fact they look quite content with their
lot Evo Cola likes the idea of dividing
a pasture into smaller areas and
rotating the livestock through them she
hopes to convince farmers in Cameroon to
do the same yeah in Germany I've learned
so much about caring for natural
resources of which I think that is
enough experience for me to take back
home and share it
[Music]
a group of disabled people also live on
the farm looking after them as part of a
vocalist job here initially she was
weary about doing it
no she's happy to help in fact it's with
these people that she's found the warmth
so often missing in farm work her
colleagues have helped her settle in and
they in turn view the newcomer as a
great addition to the farm
it's her approach to life that's so
great to live on little but also to be
able to delight in small things and her
ability to smile I thought that was
great the farm work itself is more
difficult for a vocal low because the
animals here are kept very differently
than those in her home country
these cows for example are bred for
their milk alone they're milked by
machine and for efficiency's sake
they're kept in the shed next door the
animals are only allowed outside at
specific times
I think cows in Kiruna happier than cows
yet this is one aspect of animal
husbandry in Germany that evoko defines
especially hard to bear even on organic
farms calves are separated from their
mothers shortly after birth and housed
in separate stalls in Cameroon they grow
up in the herd industrialization comes
with its own disadvantages like this
like having cows who you know stay here
in year out in the barn so when I go
back I would like to you know share my
own ideas about balancing both like
balancing industrialization as well as
taking care of the animal and making
sure they are in their natural habitat
the young farmer is clear that she won't
be promoting many of the conditions
found in industrial farming she got to
know it well during her year here in
Germany and she plans to bring back
videos to show other farmers in her
country
what is important to us it's total and
completely inorganic and not healthy but
we in Cameroon we think or what comes
from Europe is the best but then it's
not and that is one thing I'd like to
share back home that we need to promote
local production and consumption